Hi, I'm Patrick.
Hi, my name is Ai.
Nice to meet you.
We've never done this before on tape, to have the self-introduction important part,...
...but give me your standard self-introduction.
Self-introduction.
Yes.
My name is Ai Sugiyama.
And I turned pro when I was 17.
I've been a professional tennis player for 17 years,...
...and I have retired my career last year, October 2009.
Great.
And it's been a year.
And what are you doing with your free time now?
Right now, free time?
Yeah.
Well, actually my parents gave me a dog, the puppy French bulldog.
So, he's my buddy and when I have free time, I'm playing around with him.
And also, I have so much time spending with my friends.
So now, I climbed Mount Fuji this summer.
Hey! Congratulations.
Thank you very much.
So, it's like you have a whole other life starting up.
Yes, a totally different life.
That's great.
Yeah.
And is it as exciting, not quite as exciting, not nearly as exciting, much more boring,...
...how does it compare to your life as a tennis pro?
It's totally different.
Such a, how do you say? Well, a really totally different lifestyle.
Because first thing when I wake up in the morning, I have pain and aches.
Every morning when I wake up, when I was playing.
But now there's nothing, you know, no more pain and aches.
Really?
Yeah, every time I wake up so that's a good start of the day.
That's amazing.
I don't play tennis and I hurt every morning.
I feel like it every morning, yeah.
Wow.
Yeah.
And you drink more.
So, you have a headache obviously.
A headache and a sore throat, my eyes are bloodshot.